okay
just nice and calming
[Music]
hello my name is Markiplier and welcome
to depart which is uh described as I'm
in the game now
as in uh
uh
unsettlingly realistic horror game
is what it was [__] does ooh my eyes
fascinating
well
how did we do that
what
was going on here
who is deciding to mess with me today
half a gun
okay I know just about as much as you do
which is next to nothing but I do know
that walking into darkness is usually a
bad thing
I'm blind I'm wo I see something oh
hello
how the frick did I get here
I don't have anything do I
oh
I went in a circle I somehow went in a
circle and I don't know how
hello
e
what
okay
fascinating
new
there is a gun okay there's a gun over
there which is probably good for me
Maybe
okay
why
oh I opened that okay
all right I'll just go into this dark
room and grab this gun nothing bad is
gonna go wow
it's quiet
but I have a gun time to make it loud
I thought this would light some things
no apparently not oh
I get why it was doing those weird
camera things now
okay
because this is supposed to be not just
first person shooter but like body cam
style gameplay here oh man I am drunk
uh ordinarily I feel like I would be
able to
be more competent in my gun handling and
my exploration abilities will have a bad
if you've handled handle vodka
well maybe I shouldn't have done that I
don't know how much ammo has
well whatever's in there probably dead
now
and I think we can all agree
it was probably something bad
definitely something bad
hmm
I will admit having this perspective of
Gameplay at first I was against it but
now I'm like it is more immersive should
I not be jingling these
jingle jangle jingle jangle jingle
jingle no
[Music]
closed yes it worked
hey
get back here you
you better watch yourself I actually
have a gun which I think you might find
problematic
weird
this is a weird experience it's like
crossing the bridge between normal
horror games that I play they're the
first person and VR
very bizarre what's going on back here
hello
why do I need to come back here
I've already been back here
who's there
oh it's weird
I don't like it
what
oh I don't like it
this isn't a situation where the
geometry is changing so I don't know why
I'm backtracking
I'm just assuming things are going to be
changing on me when they don't
necessarily have to
oh
oh thank you can I get a flashlight
I would love a flashlight
okay I'm gonna go down this way
I just pitch black this is
oh that's wall
okay so there was nothing back here
well that felt pointless and
like it was meant to Corner me
oh
I feel like if
if Resident Evil 7
and Village kinda had this perspective
because they kind of do
like this somehow I don't know what this
game is doing but it is just a bit more
immersive
that's crazy okay but how do I open this
oh I see
Peek-a-boo I got distracted
[Music]
why
slendy man
is that you
oh great
oh good
man I wish my eyes could focus down that
way but if I had to pick the lesser of
two evils is blurry pulsing hallway or
deep dark darkness I'm gonna take the
blurriness oh why are you blurry
why are you blurry
what that was a face
a face oh I had my chance
oh I blew it
oh okay oh good pipes to nothingness
raids man I did not like that at all
I did not like that at all I feel like
I'm being led
the flashlight
even better
love that I hate it
excuse me okay
I don't get why the lighting needed to
change why did everything need to go off
what is wrong with all of you
what is wrong with every of you oh
okay close yeah I know it's closed
I gotta pause for a brief moment and I'm
gonna give everyone a chance for a
breather here just in case this is
inducing a little motion sickness
because it is a little for me I just I
haven't been playing in a VR lately
which you usually helps with this I mean
that just means that I got to get over
the hurdle of
getting back into it
like it's more immersive but in doing so
it gets closer to the realm of where
um thin a little nauseous
like it's really cool I do like the
experience and I don't want to track
from it just because I'm a wimpy baby
just gotta take it a bit slower
is it openable
no
[Music]
just nice and calming
what did you do to me
you scream blood on my eyes
what the frick was that supposed to be
hey you come back here
I'm not gonna
okay here we are
I said I wasn't gonna take no [__] from
nobody that's just gonna scream at me
like that
you better come prepared if you're gonna
come after me like that saving oh
ammo
what
oh
what did I get like explosive ammo or
something like that because I don't I
don't see an ammo counter so I hope I
haven't been running out
I'll be very irresponsible of me if that
was the case
why are you still jiggling
stop
fascinating
this way
I don't know if I trust writing on the
wall like that shoot
what
oh
all right
who's there
what's that
so I do have limited ammo I just haven't
been able to see it great good I've
wasted so many bullets
oh God
oh no thank you
oh what is it oh good keys
hey
I killed you
honestly I didn't expect that to work
uh
well I think we can all agree that uh he
deserved that
like if you're charging at me with a
spike club and screaming like that uh I
feel like I'm Justified
in my actions
oh good well good thing I didn't go that
other way that would have been stupid
all right well this is this way I don't
believe you
well I don't have a choice do I
okay
good
I can't go this
way
oh my how am I supposed to go that way
when I can't go that way
oh it was open
hey
I don't
I don't care if you are just a mask I'm
still gonna shoot you God I hope that
doesn't waste the whole clip
I did it what did I do
you know what I did
what did I do
okay
foreign
I don't like the quiet
oh very quiet
oh
interesting
fascinating okay don't know what the red
light's all about but here we go
let's do this did I open something
I forgot about this one
this one ah interesting
so I didn't go this way because I didn't
trust this way but now I'm going this
way
oh oh my God
oh my God oh my God what is this why is
there a big light on that
it's taking a little breather letting
the environment soak in a bit letting
the nausea go down a bit
what does disappear
uh
[Music]
is this one in there
oh what what what hey hey oh my God what
why hey
oh God no thank you
[Music]
what I don't even know what happened how
am I supposed to retry anything I don't
even know what I did okay uh uh again I
don't have a mouse uh
ah there we go oh good where am I I have
no idea
oh I'm back at the beginning of this all
right finally so the answer is uh don't
let them near you because it's bad
period
oh that's why there were two okay
oh [__] well I don't remember that guy
being there before
interesting
why was he there now is it because I
went that way first so the name of the
game is is don't let him near
understood
where you at
isn't there another one that comes down
this way
no
okie dokie then
gun real quiet
oh god
oh wish I could aim
[Music]
why is this not killing you big guy oh
boy there we go got him
okay great
I got him
good to know get out of the way
huh
anything
all right
I'm just gonna be a little more careful
I'm gonna go right first
hello that's weird
not sure if that's supposed to be there
okay
I thought the noise would trip
the alarm or something
this would rather not be very close when
this all goes to hell inevitably hello
okay this screaming is unnecessary all
right I'm coming in
peek-a-boo
peekaboo where are you where are you
where are you I'm out here where are you
where are you holy [__] where are they
God damn it where are you
oh god there you are
oh boy oh wow you don't go down you
don't go down
[Music]
okay so that guy just doesn't die so we
want to keep him at the end of the
hallway
uh try again I'll be right back
it'll be so much better
if the lights what is happening
if the lights didn't do that
oh God why am I out of ammo
[Music]
wow I can't shoot for [__] I am dead I'm
a dead man
got you
guys kidding that was a that was a trick
I was playing I fooled you so good
man the idiot thought I was dead turns
out no dummy
okay so if the lights could stop
flashing I would be able to finish there
you are
okay all right you're not dead but
that's fascinating there you are you're
dead now and then there's two friends
coming down this way
you're dead
oh God oh God oh God okay you're dead
you're dead you're dead you're dead
you're all dead I killed you you're dead
you're dead Okay I don't know if I have
any ammo left but I seem to be all right
well now we're back into it
and I have done I'm not 100 sure what
but I've done is there another one of
those
um
Wheels
somewhere
and uh
I need to find
robustly
oh wheel
well that was convenient okay didn't
think it would give it to me that
quickly
peekaboo
oh
well this can't be freedom
well I know oh I didn't think so I
didn't think so okay
whoa are you dancing are you doing
you're you're
okay all right I I uh
I feel like this um
I
oh oh God
uh
huh it's a game that really makes you
think huh it's an ending that really
makes you think anyway this is just a
demo I'm sure
not bad it touches on something that I
don't often see which is another level
of immersion however I feel like the
game would have been a lot better if it
didn't do that like perspective shift as
soon as you moved I like the immersion
but there was something a little
disconnected about it that was making me
nauseous and I don't I don't get like
super motion sick with games but that
one definitely was it's a similar thing
uh to VR in a way because it is that
other level of immersion and I do like
what it's going for and it somehow made
it feel scarier but I feel like it needs
some fine tuning however as a proof of
concept and a demo great loved it hope
you guys enjoyed it too if you made it
to the end uh hopefully you didn't get
motion sick and hopefully you got a few
scares out of that because I know I did
and thank you everybody for watching
check out more scary games that I've
played and stay tuned for more in the
future let me know in the comments what
you thought and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]